ندا معك بهذا الخبر ال نقلته وسائل اعلام
اسرائيليه بان مجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي
يجتمع الان في تل ابيب وسط خلافات حول اطر
التفاوض من اجل صفقه صفقه تبادل جديده
وهذا يدخلنا في الجدل المتنامي واتساع
دائره الشقاق في ظل التركيز الحديث الان
عن صفقه جديده تم تسريب بعض من تفاصيلها
من خلال وسائل
الاعلام نعم يعني واضح جدا استاذ العزيز
انه منذ حوالي اسبوع تقريبا يعني برز على
شاشات التلفزيون وفي الصحافه الخلاف الذي
يجري الان ما تتحدث عنه في مجلس الحرب
الاسرائيلي يعني على الرغم التصريحات
الخارجيه الى الاعلام التي يصرح بها
نتنياهو مثل ما قال قبل دقيقه على شاشتكم
بانه يعني هدفه في النهايه القضاء الحماس
ويقول لهم انا اقتلكم والى اخره ويريد ان
يدخل معهم في مفاوضات يعني شيء لا غير
معقول في المنطق يعني تبع في المفاوضات ان
تكون لشخص اريد ان افاوض على تحرير الاسر
وفي نفس الوقت اريد ان اقتلك يعني فيه هذا
التناقض الكبير والمجتمع الاسرائيلي يفهم
لغه نتنياهو يعني بس فقط اريد ان اعطيك
ملاحظه حتى نفهم من هو هذا النتنياهو قبل
قريل اليوم حول الساعه الحا والنص كان
هنالك تقرير في القناه 1
من سنه
2017 ونتنياهو كان لديه تقرير من الجيش
الاسرائيلي بالضبط اذا ما قرانا هذا
التقرير هو نفس العمليه التي حصلت في 7
اكتوبر بالكامل بالتفاصيل وعلى الرغم
حكومته وهو الذي يراسها مده طويله من
الزمن لم يفعل اي شيء بل اكثر من ذلك
حينما سئل نتنياهو عن هل هو يعتبر نفسه
مسؤولا عن فشل اسرائيلي لم يقبل هذا الشيء
ولذلك نتنياهو انسان يضع نفسه دائما على
شجره مرتفعه ويريد من ينزله عن هذه الشجره
ومن ينزله عن الشجره هذه انا اعتقد هو في
شخصين في داخل الكابينت كابينت الحرب الذي
الان يجتمعون معه وهم جانس و ايزنكوت
الرئيس الاركان السابق هؤلاء يعني هذان
الشخصان الشخصين يعني يعرفون تماما انه
يجب دفع الثمن الان لا يمكن قبول ان تبدا
ب مفاوضات في مرحله
جديده مع حماس دون ان تدفع الثمن وهذا
وهذا ما يحيلني دكتور محمود الى السؤال عن
ما جاء ايضا في هذا الخبر ان الخلاف حول
اطر التفاوض ما المقصود باطر التفاوض التي
هي محل خلاف الان داخل مجلس
الحرب نعم الاطار الاساسي هو يعني
في في داخل اسرائيل هو هل
هذا يعني يبقى
التفاوض في
داخل كبنيه الحرب المصغر ام انه يجب
اخراجه الى الكابينت الموسع الاسرائيلي
الموسع هنا في خلاف سياسي كبير جدا ما بين
الفرق الاسرائيليه الاحزاب الاسرائيل
المختلفه وهنالك من يريد تسييس هذه القضيه
لمصلحته الانتخابيه يعني انظر ماذا يحدث
في اسرائيل حتى نفهم الوضع انه في هذه
الظروف الحرب وفي هنالك مصيرنا على المحك
ان كانوا يعني ناس يقتلون في غزه او ناس
محتجين في اسرائيل من الاسرائيليين
ويفكرون جميعهم معظمهم يفكرون في اليوم
التالي للحرب
وهو موقعهم السياسي والان الكل واضح انه
اسرائيل لن تقدم يعني ستقدم الليله على ما
يبدو يعني طرحا جديدا ولكنه ليس بالطرح
الكريم بين قسين اقتباس يعني لنا يكون طرح
اللي يعني يرد
امال حماس لانه و ومثل ما قالوا في
الاذاعات الاسرائيليه عن على لسان يعني
المسؤولين الاسرائيليين بانه يعني يتوقعون
من امريكا يعني انظر الى هذه
العقليه يتوقعون من امريكا ان تضغط على
قطر لكي تقوم قطر بالضغط على حماس
يعني دوله او حكومه لم تستطع ان تحقق شيئا
في ال في ساحه القتال لا يوجد اي انجاز
تعرض تعرضه امام المجتمع
الاسرائيلي حكومه فاشله فشلت في كل في كل
شيء والان بدا نقاش حتى في الامور
الاقتصاديه في داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي
وفي قوه ضاغطه في المجتمع الاسرائيلي تضغط
على الحكومه الاسرائيليه وبدل انها تقوم
هذه الحكومه باتخاذ خطوه مسؤوله كما يتم
يعني العقل السليم يقبلها يريدون يعني
يطلبون ان تضغط الولايات المتحده على قطر
ومن ثم على حماس هم المسؤولون عن الفشل
يعني رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه هو المسؤول
عن اختطاف هؤلاء الناس حسب ما يفكر
المجتمع الاسرائيلي ولذلك هؤلاء الناس
يتوقعون من رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه ان
يكون على قدر المسؤوليه ويقدم مقترحا تقبل
ب حماس ومثلما نفهم حماس لن تقبل ان
يقدموا الرهائن الاسرائيليين ومن ثم تستمر
اسرائيل بقتل الاطفال الرضع الاف من الناس
تقتل يعني هذا الشيء غير منطقي الحرب حسب
المنطق يجب ان تتوقف لان اسرائيل مسؤوله
عن كل هذا الفشل ومن فشل يجب علي
ادفع الوقت الدكتور محمود يزبك الخبير
بشؤون الاسرائيلي كنت معنا من الناصره